okay we have to talk we have to talk
about the situation in kenosha wisconsin
where 17 year old kyle rittenhouse has
uh now been arrested for murder
after shooting people in what
is sort of an amalgam of the worst
of the worst of american culture gun
culture
uh reactionary culture a police
sort of um i'm not actually i'm not
talking about police but i'm talking
about people like the shooter who
sort of uh idolize and deify uh put
police-like
figures and uh want to be out there with
firearms
affecting what they believe to be some
kind of
militia or or gatekeeping i i don't even
know what to call it but the
where i want to start is that what is
very clearly
colloquially speaking murder it will be
up to the legal system to determine if
it is
legally legal murder right guilt of
of murder but what is what is
colloquially speaking murder
we are starting to see right wing media
um
implicitly or explicitly defend the
actions of 17 year old kyle rittenhouse
and i want to start with a clip from
last night's tucker carlson program on
fox news
take a look at this so are we really
surprised that looting and arson
accelerated to murder how shocked are we
that 17 year olds with rifles decided
they had to maintain order
when no one else would everyone could
see what was happening
in kenosha it was getting crazier by the
hour
so the the argument that's being made
to sort of indirectly defend the actions
of this kid are that listen if you have
chaos in the streets
and nobody else deals with it then it's
natural that a 17 year old
gun toter is going to start policing the
streets
even if you grant which i don't
that there is some problem at the
country level
of the streets being out of control
remember
overall crime has been on the decline
for a long time in the united states
even if you were to grant that which i
don't
the idea that it's natural for
gun-toting 17-year-olds to be the ones
policing the streets is absolute and
complete
lunacy now coverage of this event if you
compare it to other events
has been unfortunately the worst of the
worst that we could get from right wing
media
and even from so-called uh not
independent media from so-called
nonpartisan media
remember for example um
that the jacob blake story
was widely reported on just a couple of
days prior
and if you look at for example two new
york post tweets which we are putting up
on the screen for you on the left the
new york post tweeting about jacob blake
who was killed by police
jacob blake had a knife in his car when
he was shot by police
on the right the same new york post
with a picture of kyle rittenhouse
cleaning graffiti tweets suspected
teen gunman kyle rittenhouse
spotted cleaning kenosha graffiti before
the shooting now no mention of the fact
that
in wisconsin the minimum age to open
carry
is 18 so shooting aside
what kyle rittenhouse was doing was
against the law but of course
i guess nobody stopped him to say hey
what state are you from
and what age are you and is it even
legal for you to be here with this gun
remember that when trayvon martin was
killed by george zimmerman he was 17
years old
corporate media of course the right was
very quick to immediately say
he was 17 but this this guy was an adult
he was a big aggressive guy
and he's really an adult and he should
have he should be considered one in his
interaction with george zimmerman and
yet here
you have a gun-toting 17-year-old white
kid
also 17 uh at like trayvon martin
but this one's a kid who was cleaning
graffiti and anyway like tucker carlson
says
if the streets are out of control isn't
it natural for gun-toting 17-year-olds
to be out there policing
this is crazy this is crazy now we have
now
retrospectively found out that this kid
kyle rittenhouse i i maybe shouldn't
even be saying this kid he's 17 and
you know the legal system will determine
how he should be he should be dealt with
uh about two hours before the first
shooting
um he was actually interviewed written
house was
at a kenosha vehicle dealership by some
guy who was live streaming what was
going on in kenosha take a look at this
we're protecting from the citizens and i
just got pepper sprayed by a
person in the crowd so you had
non-weasel but
you just respond we don't have
non-lethal
so you guys are full-on ready to defend
the property yes we are
now if i can ask can you guys step back
medical ems right here
then we had another interview with kyle
rittenhouse who spoke to
richie mcginnis who's a video editor at
the daily caller a right-wing news and
opinion site
and again just stumbling across this
gun-toting 17 year old take a look what
are you doing out here obviously you're
armed and uh you're in front of this
business we saw burning last night so
what's up so people
are getting injured and our job is to
protect this business and part of my job
is also help people if there's somebody
hurt
i'm running into harm's way that's why i
have my rifle because i need to protect
myself
obviously now
i i think that there's a few different
things there's a bunch of stories here
one story as i've already pointed out
is the immediate media narratives that
are created
white kid with the gun it's just a kid
it's natural that he was out there he's
a good kid he was cleaning graffiti etc
uh even jacob blake immediately
oh well there was a knife in his car
did was that did police know that at the
time uh there's you know
claims about well there was a there was
a phone call the police may have
suspected et cetera but the handling of
these two
is completely different and that's one
storyline
the other storyline is this broader
narrative aside from this particular
case
it's the broader narrative of
republicans for months now have been
harping on
the streets are out of control joe biden
wants to defund the police which he
doesn't
everything is going to go completely
haywire if joe biden is elected
we need the second amendment and joe
biden wants to take it away
and then after all of that this kid
goes out and he actually sort of does
what would naturally follow remember the
concept of stochastic terrorism
from months and months of republicans
and trump and the rnc pushing this exact
story now the truth is that very few of
the deaths
linked to protests uh have been a result
of violence by protesters that's really
really important to understand because
the rhetoric from trump and the
conservative movement
have been painting the picture that
protesters protesting against police
brutality
have gone out there and attacked people
and killed people etc
the reality is that some of these
violent events have been
linked to movements like the boogaloo
movement which is a right-wing movement
that wants to generate a second civil
war
if you look at reviews of the different
deaths that have been linked to
protests many of them are either
unrelated or unclear if they are related
micron blanchard was shot on may 31st in
riverside illinois
by an unknown assailant in an incident
apparently unrelated to protests but
it's wrapped in
as part of the protest violence david
macady shot on june 1st in louisville
mackady ran a barbecue store was shot
and killed by members of the national
guard
when he apparently fired at them with a
handgun
the david dorn situation from june 2nd
in st
louis dorne is this retired police
officer allegedly shot and killed
by stefan cannon as dorne was responding
to a lot an alarm at a friend's business
in an area where looting was reportedly
happening
again it's not the protesters that are
out there
doing even a lot of the violence that is
reported on
so what's dangerous about this is that
when you combine this with the rhetoric
from the
rnc and from trump and the imagery and
claims that joe biden is going to let
crime run rampant
defund the police which he doesn't want
to do so on and so forth
what else do you expect so kyle
rittenhouse
has personal responsibility here the
legal system is going to adjudicate that
for sure
and yet we also can't ignore without
absolving any him of any responsibility
the environment in which this is all
being ginned up and we have to think
about what this is going to look like on
november 4th
if donald trump loses by a small margin
and that is a real concern which i'm
going to talk about tomorrow
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show we'll
have more coverage of this upcoming
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches and they're giving you up to 30
percent off
everything in their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch if you're looking for an awesome
way to
update your look the perfect way to do
it is with an elegant
high quality wristwatch when there's a
company like vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on a watch vincero
is an american company
that's made it possible to own an
excellent watch
without breaking the bank all of their
watches are
masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250
bucks i just got a watch from their icon
automatic
collection the one i got is in gunmetal
and slate blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 percent off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video